the Joe Rogan experience what you guys
do is awesome I love your music but I I
feel you're like I just want you to do
it you know just when there's little
contests and this is number one and this
one goes this and this is the band of
the year in the album over the year like
says who and why is it a contest can it
just be this is awesome [ __ ] here's some
different awesome [ __ ] why we didn't
yeah I would in bundle that was the
whole motivation behind this record was
like it was to not not partake in the
current [ __ ] in the music industry
which is so check this out
do you mind if I explain it please do
okay we had a conversation with our
manager um about this record right
you know release it and it went from
everything like we have family we don't
really want to be on the road for a
hundred days this year we don't
necessarily wanna do anything we don't
we don't want to do anything we're not
excited about you know so it came down
to the promotion and stuff and it was
basically like we want to get in front
of people and play our songs and have
fun you know and uh and the conversation
came up with about the actual album like
Warner Brothers was interested if we
wanted to bundle it which is when you
include the record like with a ticket
right and a lot of people have been
doing it whether you buy a t-shirt and
you get a record and it's a digital
download link um and I said well how
does that work and like well you uh you
would give five dollars from each ticket
back to Warner Brothers and then you
would get a record sale and I was like
that doesn't make that doesn't make any
sense to me and to Dan and they're like
yeah I thought well you would you it's
the only way you're gonna get a
number-one record so if you want a
number-one record you got to do that as
well I think well um so it's one to one
like we give five bucks back and then we
get our royalty and we get a reticular
tail right now you don't get a royalty
and you only get a tick you only get an
album sale count if they click the link
and they have like we have a fifty
percent click-through
so in other words we would pay $10 per
sale on Nielsen SoundScan by giving the
money back that we've sold on tickets to
Warner Brothers to our record label I
was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] at
this point that is a crazy deal
check out we've sold 250,000 tickets on
this tour so we would give back 1.25
million our record events for this
record was less than that so that so it
I was like if Dan and I were just on our
own record label we could give ourselves
$5.00 per ticket and count and we just
keep the beaters take the money from the
right hand to the left hand give you a
link if you counted it we get the sale
we keep the money that's basically what
the [ __ ] was going on you don't mean and
it's a it's all based on fear like all
of this [ __ ] like do you want to be
relevant you know that's basically
conversation that is basically being had
not that direct but it's like as an
artist you better try to get to the kids
good numbers get that first week up
there and Dan I basically like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] it it doesn't even [ __ ] matter
people are gonna come to the shows or
they're not gonna come to the shows
we're gonna make records people are
gonna buy them and they're not gonna buy
them and I think that is really it's
detrimental to the music industry like
to to pay too close attention to certain
metrics bands like the the whole system
right now with these majors is like
signing [ __ ] that has the most social
media interaction the most streaming and
I was like you know what when I was nine
years old I bought Vanilla Ice's Ice Ice
Baby and I listened to that [ __ ] like
I'm not joking like 250 times in a week
like a [ __ ] idiot
I think that's who's listening to this
[ __ ] there's getting a billion streams
in a month it's like [ __ ]
nine-year-old [ __ ] our fans have like
you know they got like 150 albums that
they listen to on a sort of rotation at
least and ours maybe one of them a month
and I mean some it's like it's a
different [ __ ] audience you know I
mean it's you look at Instagram and you
sees these certain people I've never
even heard their music they have and
they have like
10 million followers yeah the other
thing is that that there would be any
comparison at all like why why bother
comparing well that's exactly right
that's exactly right but that's the
problem is that there are two different
things that play at play here there's
the music injury industry itself which
is like certain people who work in
industry high ups are like we need to
sell records we need to we need like
this pop producer to work with this
writer and this artist and we need
streaming numbers and then there's
certain people you know like the old
guard like the lenny warren occur or
Seymour Stein or you know even got lots
of younger guys to but that you know
they're like actually what we're doing
is curating art that we really like and
it's either gonna sell or it's not gonna
sell and a lot of the records that we
grew up listening to most of them we're
records made by these kind of insanely
eccentric weird of people right that
never sold records but literally changed
our lives and like Captain Beefheart
being one of them
you know like Tom Waits it has sold some
records but still like he's it's a much
different type of commercial viable
thing but these artists are why we make
music you know it has nothing to do with
this [ __ ] it's like the difference
between like the Voges you know I mean
and like the Fugs it's like there's a
lot of these comparisons that you can
make about what we do in our place in
the music industry is is is to do what
we what we do and for a while we were
taking part in like the main stream
aspects of music you know we were
playing like the MTV Movie Awards and
having these insane weird experiences
only because we we hadn't done it before
and we felt like we had to do it and I
wouldn't I wouldn't chat want to change
anything but at this point like I think
steering as far away from all that [ __ ]
is is what we want to do right now yeah
there's no reason to lump you in with
anything like why would any you know
that's one of the weird things about
these award shows right you're lumping
all these different musicians together
that don't necessarily have anything to
do with each other just all make news to
check it out it's like we played the MTV
Movie Awards in 2012 we got offered to
do it we watched it when we were kids we
were in LA already it was like whatever
Aerosmith came out
introduced us and now I'm thinking like
why would they agree to do to be on the
MTV Music Awards and what what are they
gonna get from that whatever the whole
thing was kind of bizarre you know I
mean it's all really bizarre it's like
we they they need to be in the spotlight
or something you know and we were just
like I think we kind of realized how
goofy was while we were there but we got
an insane experience because we hang out
with Johnny Depp and Joe Perry and
Steven Tyler and Al and this is crazy
because after the after we do this
little song whenever we're out stage but
loud backstage by the trailers and I'm
like see Steven Tyler and Joe Perry and
Johnny Depp talking and we walk over cuz
we just want to see what they're talking
about and I'm just saying well I'm
looking at the [ __ ] they're all wearing
the craziest assess accessories like
they're dressed up like you know
Ark types of rock stars remember and
they're like talking about and Steven
Tyler and Joe Perry are talking about
transport how they're gonna get their
arsenal across state lines and I think
what like yeah man we can't we travel
with a goddamn arsenal I think what like
yeah and ar-15s
that we have [ __ ] grenades like this
is insane man oh my god I think it's
worth it we're here today just to hear
that these guys feel like they need to
travel with grenades
[Applause]